hello and welcome to the show
my name is hans kim and i am currently
underwater
what a beautiful background huh
let's
let's make this more orange to give me
more of a
more beautiful
skin tone
if i get too white
this eye is smaller than the other eye
i'm having a good time here in texas
austin texas home of the brave land of
the
under the braver
a lot of beautiful people here who are
very angry drivers they really take out
a lot of [ __ ] when they drive hans when
was roe versus wade again
uh 1942
i'm going with 1942
oops
i don't pirate mma
why would you say that
um
i love it here in texas the people here
are very angry drivers it's kind of
crazy how angry they are when they drive
i mean i think they have a lot to prove
i think that uh economically maybe
they're not at the top of the heap and
if you're not at the economic top of the
heat in america then there's a lot of
sadness so they're just like [ __ ] i
might be poor but i can get to where i'm
going fast because i'm very good at
being the best american driver
hans what do you
personally find funny
1942 100 wrong well i think that's a
very toxic way to look at facts
um
the facts aren't always just right or
wrong
a lot of it is
up to interpretation and you obviously
don't know how to feel facts like i know
how to feel facts
driving sucks
myself you wake up in the morning you
made it in life big dog great guess by
the way thanks man that's the kind of
attitude i need
it's all about
guessing with a lot of um you know a lot
of confidence
and um i don't need people doubting me
and being like oh technically roe v wade
wasn't passed in 1942 it's
the wrong way to look at history it's a
totally
uh
[ __ ] up history that you have in your
head if you think in the middle of world
war ii we were legalizing abortions when
we needed people the most we were
killing them
and to uh
forget about all the work that went into
it and the type of people that passed
roe versus wade you to think that they
were the greatest generation and not
whoever the [ __ ] they actually were
uh it shows a very deep lack of uh
knowledge and history and who the [ __ ]
you are
um in the world and what world that you
live in i don't need that what i need is
happiness and positivity and
just
blind support for anything that i say
um
it's good to be here in texas home of
the freedoms
land of the guns
um it's just a great place to be
texas
especially
if you want a gun
i love having a gun oh it's my turn
let me stop fooling around like a texas
madman
and get to playing some catan like a
[ __ ] nerd from seattle
let me put myself right here
yeah buddy
let me make myself a little bigger as i
choose my spot this eye is so small and
it's really bothering me
um but
i'm looking for a good spot with a lot
of dots
and not i don't need too much diversity
because i'll have the ability to pick
a second spot relatively quickly because
the fourth guy is gonna go twice
jagman's gonna go twice
i would like rock
and i would like brick because those are
the most precious things so i'm thinking
right here and then all i would need is
wheat
and sheep which is right here
and only right here which is kind of
worrying
because you want
a lot of options i could go here to so
these two spots are my only options for
brick or for
for this choice
another 11 i could choose is here and
then i would be wheat
rock
and brick which is going to be hard to
come back
so i'm gonna go here
and hope that i get what i need
um and then i guess i'll go
over here or here
right here here
it's really hard to say
i guess i'll go here that way it's safer
but yeah
texas it's good to be here you know once
you get texans out of their cars they're
a lot more easily manageable and easier
to deal with but when they're in their
cars they're they're a bit of a handful
hans are you single all star is 617.
well
i am not single i have a beautiful
girlfriend who i had ravenous sex with
today and yesterday last i guess just
today
because technically it was past midnight
are you gonna be on rogan this year
well you know it's really an honor that
i got to open up for him you know i
didn't even think i would know him or
that he i would i definitely would know
him because i he's the biggest man in
media but i didn't think he would know
me now he knows me
i'm just happy with that if i if
everything ends right now i get
cancelled and i get put out of my misery
i'm happy with just
having done what i have so far so so far
i'm already up ahead
uh
a lot of you losers who don't know him
at all and he doesn't know you so he
knows me
what more could i ask for
if he has me on his podcast
well here's the thing the best case
scenario is that he wants me on the
podcast and then i get on the podcast
the worst the second best case scenario
is
he
i
uh the second best case scenario is i
don't
uh he doesn't want me on the podcast and
i don't go on this podcast the worst
case scenario is he doesn't want me on
the podcast and i get on the podcast and
then he talks about how much he didn't
want me on the podcast
so
you can see that
the best thing for me to do is just not
ask at all because if i get on his
podcast and he doesn't want me on the
podcast that's going to be brutal
but if he if everything happens and
everything's positive and everything
feels good and then i get on his podcast
that is the best case scenario
and that's what i'm shooting for so i'm
not
constantly pining to get on the spot i
just want to get on when i get on in a
good way in a happy way so this is the
obvious spot for me because i need wheat
and sheep
uh or i could just double down and try
to go for something crazy but i don't
think so
and
looks like
blue is gonna want
brick
and wheat so he's probably gonna go over
here
um
red is gonna want rock and wheat
so he's [ __ ]
he can go over here for a week
so i think i'm gonna just go like this
and let the games begin
but uh yeah i'm here in texas i have a
passport and a registration to vote that
proves that i live in texas this is the
only reason i got that registration is
so i could buy
a little gun
like i have a little gun
mr920l the long
long barrel
[ __ ]
let's go baby
let's go brandon
[ __ ]
it's clear right
treat every gun like it's loaded until
it's not and then you can just fire away
oh you're not supposed to close an eye
so this is like a fun little thing that
i have no magazine in it
as you can see
you see right through that [ __ ]
so
yeah you could say that uh
i'm enjoying my time here in texas
howdy boys
y'all ready for a showdown oh
[ __ ]
this guy took my spot
an mr shadow systems mr920l
um you know what can i say it's a good
gun it's a like a glock 19
but better
what'd you say boy
boom
that's what i thought [ __ ]
i'm a goddamn
american
so yeah that's sort of my life right now
i got a gun
and
i'm just living my best life
um but uh
yeah i mean why wouldn't you get a gun i
mean
you'd rather not have a gun
it's like
a gun is a complicated piece of
machinery and hardware
that if you get good at it you can
murder people with it and you have
autonomy and self-sufficiency and
uh you don't need
uh you don't need to be afraid and you
can
physically keep yourself safe which is
something that
a lot of people prize especially men men
like to feel like they're physically
safe because if they are not
then they get really sad
because they don't feel strong or
something
um
so i'm going to try to build a city here
offer up some trades
red is far away from me blue is far away
from me
i'm gonna have to go with red everyone
wants this brick look at these thirsty
hoes
okay i'm gonna go with red
i wasn't really looking
um but i guess i want to go here
and this is best
um but yeah i mean it's it's a fun it's
a complicated piece of machinery
it's beautiful in its simplicity
uh it's
fun to get to learn how to shoot because
you see it in movies and it gives you a
level of safety and
you know a level of uh
ability to do what you want
an ability to control people which would
be nice because people are so
annoyingly uncontrollable
people are notoriously hard to control
and now i have a thing that helps me
control them in a very
very specific and sort of
uh
aggressive and scary way
which probably isn't the best but you
know it's uh it's a fun toy and uh if
other people are gonna have it then i'm
gonna have it
i trust myself with a gun more than some
of the people that i know that have guns
but it's not really about being better
than other people it's like if you were
in the middle
medieval ages
would wouldn't you buy a sword and
practice with it wouldn't that be like a
cool thing like that's the benefit of
living in the medieval times is that you
get to have a sword
um so
yeah i mean
i'm gonna have a gun in 2022. this is
the
era
you know where
you know we have the ability to have
guns and i live in america and i'm gonna
i'm gonna do the full america thing and
do cosplaying like i can [ __ ] [ __ ] up
even though i can't
um
because of a small
small uh
small arms
are not that great at defending against
the real
dangers of our society but it's fun to
pretend like it gives me any sort of
power
uh it makes me harder to kill
if you want to kill me now you have to
have more
firepower
you can't just come with the bare
minimum and like surprise me
uh
ain't no tow s tos in texas i tell you
what you're not allowed to have a gun on
stream that's not the kind of world i
want to live in i don't want to live in
a world where you can't even brandish a
gun on stream
that is ridiculous like i'm not shooting
anyone i'm not doing anything with it i
just have it
i can't even have it
i think that's ridiculous
i fully don't support that
and um
[ __ ] you if you're trying to prevent me
from
playing with a gun on stream
like you can smoke smoking kills more
people than guns
oh [ __ ] i sound like a [ __ ]
conservative
baby killer now
you should be able to shoot
sandy hook if you want to
yeah i mean it's just
like if you really want to you know
protect people or whatever then i don't
think the way to do it is to
like not let them show people having
guns
i think it's fine to show people having
guns
uh and uh what is it that you're really
protecting them from uh but yeah i love
being a modern 2022 little
crazy boy with a gun and it's like why
wouldn't i have a gun
it's 20 22 [ __ ]
um
lml
got two wood and he's red
he's also losing but whatever
let me block
red oh [ __ ] another sheep i don't need
sheep
let me give up two for this see if
anyone wants it
um
texas is good before texas i went to
a little city called denver colorado to
open up for
joe the man rogan.com
and let's just say that i had a great
time
um
four shows
uh it's crazy that um
joe rogan is has the ability to
sell out theaters
four times in a row like it's a comedy
club
uh and turn it over and all that you
know it's like a [ __ ]
whole
whole [ __ ]
theater and it's like we're treating it
like a goddamn
little
um
comedy club
um
[Music]
yeah i mean david lucas isn't the only
one with a gun he is from the hood and
all that but you know
asians can have guns too haven't you
checked out the rooftop koreans
yo i'm on rooftops
oh this guy's trying to [ __ ] with me and
only me because that's an 11 that only
i'm on
well luckily i'm just looking for some
wood right now just a hungry little wood
farmer
um but if i get an ele if i had gotten
an 11 i could get a
goddamn
city right away
um
but yeah i mean i have a gun now i
bought a gun i bought a bidet to clean
my [ __ ] which is nice
i uh
i have a uh
uh
i bought a salt gun fifty dollars it's
[ __ ] expensive the bidet was cheaper
than the goddamn
not bidet the salt gun
um
uh
you're going to seattle anytime soon i
am wooly nutner i am going to seattle my
hometown
in
august
august the first week of august on
tuesday i'm going to play at tacoma
comedy club thursday i'm going to pl or
wednesday or thursday
thursday i'm going to play at
laughs comedy club in the u district
and then um
and then
friday saturday i'm going to play
in richland washington in the tri-cities
near kennewick where the kennewick man
was found
on the tri-cities oh he blocked my wood
i needed that wood and he took my break
why is everyone stealing from me
i hate that we all have three points
please steal from others as well
exclamation mark
because i think the robber
has only been stolen from me
someone from lml from drag man
lml
from me from me from me
from me
oh
only oh [ __ ] he's coming at me
arguing with people
can you be a guest on my brother's
podcast probably not
i don't really enjoy doing podcasts
i enjoy doing my own podcast like this
this is fun for me um because it's easy
i can just do it anytime
um but um
i don't really enjoy the whole podcast
thing
honestly
um
unless it's like
someone that i know
i mean
i enjoy podcasts it's just i don't enjoy
getting up and going somewhere and all
that you know if it's super convenient
and easy and on the way
um
do i think pete davidson is funny yeah i
think he's done some funny stuff oh my
god are you serious is he only they're
only taking they're only blocking my
[ __ ] that's what you get for being in
the center
um but uh yeah i mean uh
it's just sort of weird how like people
think that just because they have a
podcast that like no
[Music]
you have to do it like it's an honor to
do anyone's podcast
but podcasting is hard it's a lot of
work and
it's not like
it's not free it's like it takes time
out of your day and it's not uh
easiest thing to do
um
so yeah i mean everyone's like
i mean
yeah i mean
unless you have like a big following
or something
it's really not worth it
god damn it
that's six being blocked he's killing me
killing me i tell you and no 11's have
been rolled since the beginning of the
game
but uh this is fun i've been just
playing katana a lot um it's really
addicting and hypnotizing
uh it's a good time
um
so
another thing that's going on is that uh
you know i'm doing some theaters and
stuff
in other parts of this world i'm going
to chicago i'm playing at zany's soon
so come check me out at zany's um
next weekend i'll be in chicago so
that'll be fun
and uh you know i need a place to show
people where i'm at and stuff
i don't think i can do anything which
sucks let me try to get a rock
that way i can buy a robber
to [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] up with
come on [ __ ]
ooh
yes i will thank you very much
okay got a robber
see evan
um
yeah i mean i'm having a good time just
chilling out um
what else is going on what is it like
hanging out with joe rogan it's like
this
[Music]
intensity
and awesomeness all the time
um it's like
he's such a force of nature he's a very
powerful human being literally and not
just because he says it all the time
harvesting a toddler's organ in doings
read duane reed bathroom
dwayne reed bathroom dwayne reed is the
thing only in new york slash the east
coast slash
i've only seen it in new york so i don't
know where else it's
at
um you know the crazy thing about
um mr rogan is that he lives such an
intense life like all the [ __ ] that he
does is [ __ ] dope and awesome
um
and it's crazy because
like
um
sure
because like uh
he uh everything he does is so intense
and awesome that like
um
everything is [ __ ] dope in his life
what
why would you do that
you're an idiot
your road goes nowhere [ __ ]
i roll the two let me steal from someone
try to get a rock
who has a rock
um let me steal from
this guy because he has the most number
of points
now i just need an 11. eleven hasn't
been rolled in a while but uh what's not
been rolled in the past is not
indicative of what's going to be ruled
in the future like it doesn't matter if
seven elevens have been rolled
in a row the probability that an 11 will
be rolled on the eighth time is the same
probability as if all those other roles
hadn't happened so it doesn't really
matter
it really doesn't matter
my friend it doesn't really matter
so the only place i can go now is like
here or here
which is interesting
now no one has the longest road i took
his longest road that was so funny
lost along this road and no one got it
in its place this guy [ __ ]
he built these three roads for nothing
for absolutely nada
that's what you get if you [ __ ] with me
i'm stuck in cali still hella wanting to
move to austin oh my god on my beautiful
six
that's most of my [ __ ] [ __ ] is around
the six
come on
baby old is hans kim 32 the president's
pilot with louie and shane was the best
podcast i've seen in a while
well you know that's kind of rude
because i'm sort of doing a podcast
right now that's like going up to a girl
and being like this girl amanda is the
hottest girl i've seen in a while well
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're looking at me right
now you're telling me that i'm not the
hottest [ __ ] you've seen
well you know i don't have any illusions
or delusions you know i am what i am and
i
am a very mediocre looking girl so it's
fine you know i'm stuck in cali still
hella wanting to move to austin just
tell my
just all my family is here and i know it
would benefit me to move out of
california so much
yeah move out of california if you want
to
how do you think it would benefit you
what do you think are the benefits of
california versus texas or texas versus
california
come on [ __ ]
um
i think that california is a great place
um
[Music]
i think that uh
if we give him one he'll give me weight
i'm fine with that
um
[Music]
oh thank god
i think california is fine i think you
should stay in california if you want
um
uh you know california
i think it's a great place i mean
honestly all the places in america are
pretty much the same now it's all strip
malls and [ __ ] so
is there really a real reason to move
out of california
or nay
oh my god how many bricks have been
rolled
this was just my luck
oh thank god
put it on the red
dude
um yeah i mean what is i mean some
people just want to go to a new place
just to go to a new place which is fine
it can jumpstart your [ __ ] um
but uh i'm i mean
every city is just a city
uh you can do anything you want to do in
pretty much any city unless there's like
some prohibitively
[ __ ] up [ __ ] going on like west
virginia or some [ __ ] but pretty
much everywhere is the same now
especially with the internet you can
just do anything anywhere obviously for
my situation moving to austin has helped
me out quite a bit
so i'm not going to say that
it's
that you should or shouldn't do whatever
i mean i moved to austin and it helped
me out so maybe moving to austin is the
solution
um but
um i think that uh
moving is like looked on as like this
cure-all thing and i think like uh
overall just
making your life work where you are is
ow
[ __ ] okay well i'm trapped here
i literally can't go anywhere else
that little [ __ ]
spent all his money to block me off
can't go here i can't go i'm i'm stuck
here
stuck in this little tiny [ __ ]
area so i'm just gonna have to get
victory points
and
nights and [ __ ]
it's gonna have to be my life
because i can't do [ __ ]
um
texas is great
in the fact that
the workers have no rights and
everything is prohibitively
far away
and
that there are no uh rights for
minorities
um
but other than that it's a great place
i should have done that
um yeah i mean i think it's a great
place just because uh it's so open and
free and
available
and
you know
it's like the people here are
interestingly self-sufficient
i think the things that are bad about it
is the lack of
rights
the lack of uh health care and like sort
of the attitude that everyone should
just
survive on their own and there's no sort
of
group unity
except amongst the rich
and
the general lack of
[Music]
labor rights and all that like thinking
about and like marijuana is illegal here
but life in austin for me is great as
long as you don't get caught up in their
uh criminal justice system like i know
my girlfriend went hiking
and some guy
would just didn't like them because
there were three women
and two of them were let i mean all of
them are technically lesbians
but
he just didn't like the cut of their jib
and so he called the cops on them had
them arrested for hiking and they had
the gps to be like no we didn't trespass
and he was like no i hate you [ __ ]
liberals coming in
and trespassing on my property
and it was like
they weren't trespassing and she got
arrested and had to pay like thousands
of dollars
she had to be sober and not piss in a
cup
just because some guy wanted to [ __ ]
with them and that's the kind of thing
that can happen here in texas is this
you can weaponize a criminal justice
system for your use
and uh yeah it's i hate i hate that [ __ ]
that's that [ __ ] makes me [ __ ] crazy
um
and there's literally nothing you can do
because it's this whole thing is like
we're not going to take care of society
and we're not going to make sure it's
good we're just going to leave it and
whoever gets to control it gets to
dictate what happens in here
and
it creates a pretty
toxic environment um where people can
just
treat each other like [ __ ]
um
but
yeah i mean other than that it's great
um i just um
i just think that uh it could be a lot
better
uh
if we
admitted that we're a society instead of
pretending we're not and pretending like
we're just independent proprietors that
are out to [ __ ] each other up
um
and admitting that uh the best way to
make a society better is to
admit that we're a society and then work
to improve it
um but
yeah what are you gonna do
let's see if anyone wants anything
but uh yeah i mean uh it's it's just
like if you get caught with weed
or if you get caught speeding then they
can [ __ ] with you
and that's kind of
annoying uh what do i i don't really
want that
i actually need to
oh god what a useless [ __ ] thing i
just got
already maxed out on roads
i cannot go anywhere else
but uh yeah i mean
ted cruz and greg abbott are the worst
yeah they want to facilitate the
transfer of wealth from the poor to the
rich
they just want this to be a playground
for rich people
and what a waste this guy's gonna get
the longest road now
i need a win quick
and i don't see that happening
look at the upside be happy you're not
one of them that is my get down
though it is gardening other stuff
besides read but cannabis
um
colorado seems to be doing it right
nowadays
what game is this this is katan i am
hella interested in this game you're
playing but seem kind of confusing
um well they have like a little tutorial
here
uh
rules
how to play katan hello
welcome to columnist dot io an online
alternative to settlers of catan
the objective the objective of the game
is to reach 10 victory points before the
other players
points may be gained through building
settlements upgrading upgrading to
cities
buying development cards or achieving
the longest road or largest army in
order in order to build and achieve
these things
you'll need some resources
this is taking forever
it's just a game it's fun don't think
about it too much
uh i guess i'll go here
whoa
i bought that [ __ ] oh i didn't want to
buy that [ __ ] i wanted to do this [ __ ]
that looks kind of cool
oh maybe i should have done this one two
three four five six seven eight
it doesn't really help me
yeah i don't think i'm going to win this
game i'm going to start another game
because this game is [ __ ]
i can't say mofo god damn it this
[ __ ] cucks
honestly i think the censorship laws in
uh katana are kind of helpful because it
keeps it more
civil
because um
then you can't talk so much [ __ ] you
can't get to the extremes of whatever
you know you gotta kinda keep it level
headed and that's that's good
euros i got three euros
hopefully they convert that [ __ ] what am
i gonna do with euros
um
i think that um
i think that uh there
could be a lot of changes to texas
one such change i would like to
implement is health care for human
beings
um oh nice i got another game going
this game is kaput
two games at the same time
baby
um
i mean obviously i don't want to ruin
the thing that makes texas great but i
don't think taking care of your people
will ruin texas
in fact i think it'll make it better
um i think that uh overall like you got
to treat society like it's a society and
not try to be like the purpose of
society is to make my life better and to
for me to play around with it and for
rich people to
subjugate the poor
i think a lot of that comes from racism
because black people were not seen as
americans
so you can do whatever you want to the
poor and it's not really that big a deal
because it's not really you it's these
other people
and
[Music]
i think it's really toxic horrible way
to
function
um
and i think it's uh
it's the root of a lot of the issues in
america and slavery and how we treated
poor people and slaves and black people
and we just
got used to treating ourselves shitty
and so we just kept treating our poor
people shitty
which i think is horrible this is a
really tough board i don't know where
the [ __ ] to go
uh
9 10 11 12.
i don't know 11 11 right here
uh 10 10.
it's really hard to find a good diverse
spot
i think i might just go with this 11
spot
even though it's
not that good
because now i need brick wood i need
wheat
sheep and rock
i need it all
oh great
let me try to get a rock gumrah
gumrah has 12.
let's see
i need a rock
i think umrah is the only one that has a
lot of lot of rock
so gumrah is blue
so let me [ __ ] over blue
i got a rock
okay now i have seven points on the next
turn
and uh i can get another city
i'll have eight
what does health care for human beings
look like i'm from texas but i have
lived overseas for 12 years now when i
went back i was able to get an urgent
care center and get fixed up by actual
doctors
yeah i mean that's great but it's
obviously
uh the american healthcare system is not
ideal like we're not trying to save
lives we're trying to make money so
whatever it takes to
make money is what we're going to choose
to do
and not necessarily to
[Music]
save lives and i think that to focus on
saving lives
would help us it's just the wrong
incentives and you know like you could
go to an urgent care you probably have
money or you probably have some uh
help
or like you're in a fight a
fortunate situation but a lot of people
that aren't in a fortunate situation
uh you know die because they can't
afford insulin
or they are in hospitals and they they
are get in debt
um
i mean it's not a system set up for
people to be successful or to be
it's not set up to save lives so i think
just a focus on saving lives would make
it better instead of this toxic system
where everyone's trying to fight each
other and [ __ ] each other up like we
should be able to do in the usa if we
were really free to make our own
decisions
how can people find dates to see you do
stand up as well as william montgomery
it's on my instagram mostly
it's on my calendar too
it's hard for me to [ __ ] have a place
where i have everything set up
but i should do that i should have like
a place where
[ __ ] is all
organized and stuff
um
i don't really need
nothing
everyone has more points than me
okay
red
um these are i think the us system can
be approved up
improved upon or approved upon
let's switch to the other game
okay
i'm black i need sheep
wheat
sheep wheat
and rock
i could build here
built here
i'm gonna go here and then go down
unless there's a tree port
and then i'm gonna build towards rock
well uh the american system could
definitely be
improved upon i'm really impressed with
the swiss style of private health care
yeah i mean if if we start treating
everyone like they're americans instead
of like having an underclass that we
treat like the other
i think we need to look at ourselves as
a whole because what happens to all
americans happens to us
but let's take a look at the calendar
this next weekend i'm going to chicago
for the whole weekend
and then come back on sunday but i'm
doing thursday friday saturday shows
thursday i'm in downtown chicago friday
saturday i'm in rosemont
so i'm excited it's a i'm headlining and
uh it's gonna be a fun show
um
you know i'm gonna be in chicago it'll
be fun and then i'm going to
uh detroit with joe rogan
um
uh
oh [ __ ]
so confusing
okay i can't do [ __ ]
um
[Music]
let's
steal
lmlj has
something now
let me steal from him again
ah
wait
i don't want this
he has eight points
i really don't want to trade with anyone
okay fine
rock
let me get another
little guy
but uh yeah i'm doing that then i'm
doing
stuff
in austin
[Music]
and then
i'm doing fort worth hyenas
fort worth texas
near the whatever that i'm in dallas
again on saturday
doing stuff in austin
i don't know who josh smith is
uh shantae addison
addison texas i think that's near
houston
then i'm doing detroit in boston
and then i'm doing las vegas with joe
rogan
and then i'm doing
and uh
show in florida
then in
seattle
and then i might go to canada
but yeah that's pretty much it so i'm
all over the place
oh god
he won
the red one
yeah but uh yeah i'm having a good time
doing a lot of stuff
going out all over the place
um
i should have gotten rock baby
well there you go now i can build a
settlement
oh and i got another brick
you can never have too much brick
um
but most of the trees are very nice
unfortunately it takes like five years
for the roads to get so it can be
i would like to see texas cities built
properly instead of just giant
thoroughfares
for trucks to zoom through i like to see
them built a little more compactly so
you can walk because we are humans after
all and to make cities for humans is
ideal for humans so instead of making
cities for cars it'd be great if we can
make cities for
um
for human beings so that we can walk
around
and stuff um it'd be great if we could
uh
have more public transit so you didn't
have to choose a car
like if you're all about freedom then
you should have the freedom to
um
not have to take a car
um
i think it'd be great if we
had uh legalized drugs and we didn't
criminalize people
for just existing
um but other than that you know what i
like about texas is like the the
idea of like you can do whatever you
want no one can stop you everyone is
unique and you have to respect everyone
because you they might have a gun so in
texas characters are rewarded uh you can
be eccentric and weird and you still
have bodily autonomy and uh the right to
live because everyone can have a gun so
i think that's nice i think the
badassery is great i just don't think
you can build a very functional society
with too much
of that i think you need to temper that
you need to be like okay that's a fun
little game that we play but besides
that we also need to have functioning
sewage systems and
infrastructure and networks of
transportation
i think it takes
a bunch of [ __ ]
um but other than that you know i think
it's great
that people in texas have
um you know a lot of
autonomy and
they they seem to be having a lot of fun
um
yeah i mean uh
what do you think
let's see if i was looking at places in
flugerville can you recommend any
affordable nice places yeah look around
uh riverside is great because it's close
to everything but cheap
uh you can get a shitty little apartment
there
um
other places
hands used to be more politically
incorrect t y
thank you time to catch a fan fish as
big as you with david
um i mean politically incorrect i think
is a good way to be i don't think it's
good to be politically correct i think
it's weird
i think that you should be free and you
should be able to say and think whatever
you want to say and think
um
i think um
changing what you think for other people
is not a good way to think
i think it makes you
not a great thinker
i think just
saying and believing what you want to
say
is ideal
[Music]
let's go here why not
should i go here
if i go here
i'll go here
yeah you should take a dab or a bong rip
right now if that's what you want to do
um
[Music]
i think that uh
i had a great time at uh the denver
theater the uh
bellco theater in denver colorado you
know
we got there you know we stayed at a
nice hotel and
we uh
we got there like in the morning and
then we just sort of relaxed
which was nice
[Music]
and then we
we woke up
we went to dinner i was late for dinner
they were all waiting for me
and then i showed up and i was like
sorry guys mostly all the biggest
comedians in the world were waiting for
me
then i got in late and
we had a great dinner
at a nice restaurant and then we went to
the show and then i set up my camera
um i love setting up my camera it's sort
of like a meditative practice because
you get to meet the video people there
and you get to hang out and
um
it's uh
if i didn't set up a camera if i didn't
have an excuse to go out there i would
have just stayed in the green room the
whole time but the fact that i had a
reason to be out there
uh it was great uh it put me out there
and
you know
it was a great time
um but yeah it was it was fun uh i i met
the camera guys there were some
down-to-earth
people
like this camera guy is like they uh
they don't give a [ __ ] about anything
like to them it's just a job and they're
like they're cynical they're like what
are you doing comedy yeah i remember
comedy i've never done it before but
i love the idea of it and i have mastery
of things even though
i've never done it because i've read
books or something so it was cool to
talk to that guy
i mean he's just so over everything it's
just but then i met like some of the
ushers like in between sets
uh when they would switch over the
theater for another whole sold out show
it would just be an empty little place
um so that was cool
um
yeah uh
it was like the ushers were there they
were all [ __ ] shooting the [ __ ] there
were people cleaning up
and then there are the people that show
people to their seats
uh it was just a crazy experience
oh [ __ ] i have eight now i might seven
myself oh thank god
okay so i'm gonna do this
and then i'm gonna do this
boom
and now i'm in the lead
so i might want to build here to get the
longest road or i might want to build
here but both of them get three to one
ports which is good
um
yeah it was cool to just see that whole
[ __ ] place empty it was a great
experience uh to see it in between like
when you go to a place like the bellco
theater you're used to seeing it in one
sort of uh
little way that you see it
[Music]
but to see it in between it's like
seeing someone with their makeup off or
like they're changing it's like you get
to see a different side of that theater
and that was pretty cool to see
um
and it was more a practical place this
is like a place with a physical form
that
has to be navigated to
utilize it to the best of its abilities
or whatever
red rock should be a cool place for a
show
top five top comics outdoors
road rock is outdoors so it's not the
best place
uh so we did two shows friday
had a dinner in a diner
which is crazy going anywhere with joe
rogan he has top-notch security so that
was pretty cool um
and then we went back to the hotel i
went swimming it worked out had a good
time
um
[Music]
but yeah it was a fun fun time
um
oh god
[ __ ]
i'll be roller 7 now
[ __ ]
um
[Music]
so
what else is going on
i've never tried playing crusader kings
now
um
[Music]
tuesday night i might be a vulcan i
never know
it's really a mystery
nice
who has rock so i want a rock so i can
build a city
so i'm probably going to move it to
rojas
even though he only has four points
he did steal from me though
this [ __ ] up red too which is nice
come on rock [ __ ]
one two three four
give me a rock
boom
this is seven points this is eight
points
i need more rock than i do need
wheat
and [ __ ] and sheep
i'm just gonna go here
build here
and wait my turn
child talked about his security what was
that like
i can't really tell you what his
security is like because that'd be a
security breach his security is so good
that i don't can't even talk about it
because i'm a part of his security
i'm a part of the security
the security starts here loose lips sink
ships
so i don't really want to say too much
rojas
[ __ ]
um let's block their brick
this brick is precious
i mean they both have multiple bricks
so this wood
okay that's fine
god damn it
people just keep [ __ ] with me
they really hate me
they hate us because they ain't us
what do you think about san antonio or
do you ever get there or just stay in
austin i go to san antonio san antonio's
great
um
[Music]
it's just a city i mean what what can i
say about a city it's like
it exists
it's great oh my god seriously they
cannot stop stealing from me
that is so crazy
how many times i've been stolen from if
i didn't have that [ __ ] there i would
have a [ __ ]
thing right now
i would have a city right now
[ __ ]
i need to buy my own security this is a
night
um but yeah
joe rogan security is formidable and
that's all you need to know about that
don't even try [ __ ]
they will [ __ ] your [ __ ] up
i worked out i was hitting the heavy bag
and i was i checked i went into the gym
no one was there like i mean there were
people there but just normal boring ass
civilians were there
um
and
i uh
i i was just
like oh no one's here so i was just
hitting the heavy bag like an idiot just
having fun with it i don't like working
out so if there's a heavy bag that's the
first thing i'm gonna go to i like to
have fun
i don't like to just you know
people oh [ __ ] stole my road
um
i don't just like to
mindlessly work out like a robot
so
[Music]
hopefully they stop stealing from me
these jealous little [ __ ]
why
i'm not even winning
it's just a habit they just can't help
themselves
it's crazy how many times they stole
from me
i take from red because i'm not a
[ __ ] idiot
like all these other idiots
i could wait for a brick
i could wait
i don't like waiting though
um
i really don't want to get sevened
that's good
that's fine i have security now
it's really sad that joe rogan cannot
have his normal life
a normal life he cannot go to grocery
stores shopping et cetera
yeah i think he's fine i think overall
he's living an amazing life
i think going to the grocery store is
something that i would give up if i
could have 17
000 million trillion dollars
it's a little bit of a
um
yes
um
yeah i would love to be on jre i would
love to do it the right way though
and uh
i think it's great when comedians get on
jerry
[ __ ] dude seriously that [ __ ] sucks
um
let's see
red and blue are winning
um
[Music]
i don't like blue
[ __ ]
i might as well just spill the road
yes
anyways can you give me joe's personal
cell
here's the thing it's like very very
important that i don't ruin my
relationship with joe rogan so when you
guys tempt me and like ask me for things
and i have to say no to you it just
makes me
harden my shell to the public and to
my beautiful subscribers
anyways hi hans you and williams need to
come to detroit i am coming to troy i'm
going to the fox theatre with joe rogan
and then i'm gonna do a headlining show
there
or somewhere
soonish
stay tuned
one two three i need one more
sheep or wheat or something
um
i need something
i should use my robber
just because i need to shake things up a
bit
one two one two three
let's just steal from this [ __ ]
another rock
how completely useless
i can get two of any cards
um i might get
i might get a development
card
oh god i don't know what to do
um
[Music]
oh i can get a city [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah
okay
that's a 12 wow what a coincidence
oh
look at that they took my [ __ ] again
um
how do you get over a bomb on stage
usually by
getting over i get over it by
um i usually get over by doing another
set
and
trying to do well
oh my god
no fives
um
i try to write jokes any way i can
holy [ __ ] this guy connected his [ __ ]
there's no way i'm getting along this
road now
so stupid how much they attack me
one two
three four
oh i can build a settlement
why is it a gg you guys are [ __ ]
stupid
i only have nine
relax
i can't even get another city
so i need to go for victory points or
what an idiot
oh my god he stole all my weight
anyways
what have i done for mother's day
oh my god they're
blocking me off
so i think that
these people
are
blocking me off and then
i'm responding by like talking [ __ ] to
them being like look how you're blocking
me off and [ __ ]
and they don't like that
one two
three four five six oh my god
okay
well
[Music]
let's see if they want to trade
if any of them trade then i win
so they're probably not going to do it
um
what can i get
i need wheat
i'm probably gonna get sheep so i'll
just do this they're probably gonna
steal from me oh wait i have a port
this still doesn't help me
now i pray for sheep and no robbers and
no winning
foreign
um
i'm black
so um
what else is going on
the whole issue with uh dave chappelle
is kind of interesting
because dave chappelle was
attacked
and that's kind of sad
thank
thank
you
[ __ ] animals
they blocked me 11 times and stole from
me 12 times and still i got second
he's [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh he won with a development card
he had nine points too
he must have had a victory point
hidden away
but yeah uh
i'm uh playing katan
talking [ __ ] to people
i
give your mom a joke
let's see
11 right here
uh 11 right here
oh this is a nice spot 12.
i'll go here why not
thank you
so each turn you pick what resources you
get from your settlement no
you roll and then whatever you roll
gives you the settlement in the
beginning you choose where do you start
out do you have a favorite moment out of
all the moments you've currently
experienced
a favorite moment
i mean i enjoyed kissing all the chicks
i enjoyed hanging out with famous people
i enjoyed
getting to share my ideas on stage you
know like
yesterday i did a set and i realized
like you know it might not always be
like the funniest
uh set
is mine but as long as i can i can
communicate my ideas across
that's all that really matters
um
yeah i mean i think that uh overall
brick and sheep
i think overall like
it's sort of weird because
um
uh
yeah i mean i love communicating ideas i
think that's the most important thing
like even if i'm up there i'm just like
i'm i'm telling them what i think this
is like an idea that i'm putting in
their heads and even if i don't get a
laugh or if they don't think i'm the
funniest person at least i get to
i need to make that idea a good one like
sometimes i'll be at a show
and
it'll be like really chaotic and people
won't be listening and it's easy to just
go into that and be like oh they're not
listening and it's chaotic and be like
what and just talk to the people that
are creating the chaos but then you lose
the people that are actually listening
so i think a better strategy is to
talk to the people that are listening
and are paying attention and are
listening to you in the correct way and
reward them for that reward
the people that are listening
uh by giving them a coherent idea
and creating
a world with your words that is uh
they're able to latch on to
um
and if you do that then they'll pay
attention to you
and then they'll be rewarded and it's
positive reinforcement instead of
yelling at the people doing it wrong you
speak to the people that are doing it
correctly
and
and you give them like
the ability to listen to you or the
opportunity
and i think that's really an important
thing to do
um
i could kind of go for this spot
uh yeah so like as long as i keep the
idea
coherent then
it it'll be
a thing that they are able to listen to
and i think that's
important to do
four five
uh four five six seven
seven this is eight
but here i have the opportunity to go
here and i have the wood port so
i'm just gonna go here
i'm probably going to go for the wood
port first
i might want to go for this first but it
would take a long time to get
actually wouldn't take that long
yeah i think i'm going to go for this
first because this is under contention
but no one is even close to this so
i'm going to go for this first because i
have
this brick
right here so i just need one more to
build a settlement here
i just don't want orange to [ __ ] with me
if orange builds a road somewhere then
i'll [ __ ] figure it out
but uh yeah i mean
that's what i want to do is
uh i want to
uh speak to the people that are actually
paying attention and not to the ones
that aren't
okay he built the road there which is
good
um let me build a road here then
and get the wood port so that it's
easier to do everything else should i
no i want to go here i feel better about
going here also i think another
important thing in comedy is to feel out
your jokes and feel out the audience and
be in tune with your emotions i think a
lot of people
like especially nerds that get into
comedy get into it
for the
analytical side and they don't feel it
out as well
i think it's important to feel it out
because if you
like how i chose this spot to go to it
just felt better to me
than this spot and
i mean who knows why i felt better or
worse for going at this spot but
i did
and so this is what happened so it's
like you know it's i think it's
important to be true to your emotions
and uh
to
because your emotions are smart in a way
that you probably don't even realize
so i mean when i the way i figure out
how to tell keep telling a joke or not
is if i enjoy telling it if i have joy
telling it then that means i should
probably be saying it more but if i
don't enjoy saying it that means i
shouldn't be saying it because my
emotions are smart and you gotta listen
to your emotions
um i don't live in a van i'm currently
in a home right now
which is pretty nice
um you feel out your ukrainian gf before
she came over
yeah i felt her
inside and out if you know what i mean
um
yeah i mean i think that uh
it's important to feel because i uh
obviously am more of a thinker than a
feeler so i've had to with comedy learn
how to feel
because i'm in clubs and bars every
night of the day talking with people so
it's important to feel correctly and
know people and
figure it out
dina
sure
hopefully he [ __ ] with orange
[ __ ] with orange [ __ ] with orange
oh now i just need his wheat oh yeah
he's [ __ ] with orange
yeah
[ __ ] you orange
me trading with him helped
oh god
i need a wheat
wait
nice
now we got to keep all my [ __ ] things
too
okay well that's annoying that that's
blocked
but you know it's fine
i might go up here next after i get this
wood port
come up here get this rock
and more wood
and then i could go here too
the world's my oyster
what a beautiful time
to be alive
um but yeah uh i spend a lot of time
outside socializing and [ __ ] which i
think was important for me because i'm
more of a not socializer
i'm more of a capitalist than a
socialist i'm more of an introvert
so i think being out in public is good
because it forces me to be out
it forces me to do [ __ ]
uh which i think is important
orange got [ __ ] to this game
he could still win anyone can still win
um but uh it's gonna be a little bit
harder now for this talk [ __ ] talking
piece of [ __ ]
oh should i trade with him
sure i want a city
oh [ __ ] i kind of regret that now so if
i get seven i won't be able to build a
city
um
yeah so i think it was good i've been
out
talking to people and doing [ __ ]
so
oh maybe i shouldn't have traded with
him
come on [ __ ]
no one wants to trade with you
and your turn
[ __ ]
oh
that's painful
i gotta build the city
but yeah i think it was great that i've
been out socializing
even though i didn't always want to
the most useless victory point
is the one that you get from a
development card
um but yeah i mean i think it's
important to go out and socialize and be
a social person and i think it opens up
your brain in a way that
is not possible playing catan all day
um
i think
we should have a more robust economy
maybe that might be nice
and i think the way that you get a
robust economy is by spreading money out
to the whole society instead of just to
the rich i think that people want to
just give money to the rich because
they're unimaginative
this guy's getting so [ __ ] by this
robber on the six it's beautiful to see
because that's his only wood and he
can't build [ __ ] he has no rock
so the only thing he can do is build
roads
but unfortunately he can't build any
roads because the six is blocked
if i were him i'd get a knight
but
he's just trying to build a lot of [ __ ]
that's too bad i mean i think he might
get this spot but
what are you gonna do
um
yeah i mean i think that uh
having the economy be structured the way
it is is not beneficial to anyone but
the rich
and we just do it this way because we
uh
want to we
we
are being ruled over by billionaires and
[ __ ]
so that's kind of unfortunate the
factory that makes iphones in china is
where they put nets outside the window
to work is can't suicide
yeah we probably should be creating a
more
healthy beautiful world
oh thank god
let me [ __ ] over blue
blue 42
sheep are wait
when you're trading with orange though
wait
sheep
i need sheeps
red
nice
well that worked out
um
yeah the suicide nets and factories i
mean i think china is very pro
restrictive in the way that they do
things
and i don't think it's healthy
um
i think that
china needs to get their [ __ ] together
stop being [ __ ]
this [ __ ] doesn't even have
sheep
we got a 10 i got a city
which is nice
i'd rather get a city
and 11 would be nice too
but i need a lot of elevens
oh i have the wood port now too
much
he blocked me off
he knew what i was going for
for muck
wood was that a six that was a six
week sheep
would
give me a ten
he needs a sheep so bad
no one likes you dude relax
um
[Music]
yeah the chinese nets the factory nets
and [ __ ] that's terrible brandon shaw
thinks hans kim is the reason no one
likes him ever since that video where he
crossed the street and hans intimidated
him damn nine cobb with the [ __ ] hans
kim knowledge
yeah i saw brandon schaub crossing the
street once that is true
and i did videotape that incident
and now i've met him in person so that's
kind of cool
so many
sheepy whatevers
let me get a brick
and let me build
this away
i'm going to go for this
and then
i'm going to go for this or this
try this
ooh
going to go for a city probably right
here so i can get all these woods
with misses
which might be more precious
than
the
other one this is five six seven this is
seven nine
i'm gonna have to go for this one
okay doing good this game
my only competition is blue i have a
robber so i can place that [ __ ]
on him anytime he [ __ ] starts acting
up
um
you should come play a show on atl i'd
love to i'd love to do the laughing
skull i think i can sell that little
[ __ ] out it's attainable
i should message people and start
booking [ __ ]
every weekend going out i like being
here though when i go out and i come
back i'm a little discombobulated and
takes me a while
to reconfigure myself
come on [ __ ]
that is a threat everyone's a threat you
can never count anyone out in content
i can say something funny you should
come play a show on atl
um so i think that overall the
funniest thing is
um probably
joe biden
joe biden brend
brandon
connolly
um i think i want to go this way
from here
to here
to here
so what should i talk about
um
i think that china has nets on their
[ __ ] thing because they're an
oppressive place and they just like
[ __ ] [ __ ] up and stuff
um i think that
we should not try to be more like china
uh damn he got so much [ __ ]
um
one two three
i got three cards and i need four for a
settlement
hopefully something rolls in
this guy is [ __ ]
yeah we'll just see it
if i get a 10 that changes everything
jesus christ this guy takes
forever i'm 32.
there are job openings for every
available worker now is the time when
employees have more leverage to wage
negotiate
or unionize that's true this is a good
copy pasta
we should uh unionize and work hard and
do all that [ __ ]
nice
i'm going to build a little seti
said he meant
it
i like that [ __ ]
robber where it is oh [ __ ] he moved he's
gonna move it
probably to my eight because i'm the
biggest threat
[ __ ] luckily
i don't need you
hot damn
eight nine
i'm gonna move it on my turn
this guy's gonna take forever
red is
slowly becoming a threat
maybe i should [ __ ] up red
it's hard to [ __ ] up red it's easier to
[ __ ] up blue
blue definitely orange oh orange has
points with
some [ __ ]
oh thank lord
thank the lord god almighty oh wait i
can win
how many has five oh yeah i can
definitely win
i am a winner
[ __ ]
not even close
doubled your [ __ ]
six look how many sixes were rolled in
fives
were not rolled and fours were rolled
five six i was sort of on a six
uh four
let's see
i got blocked
he got blocked 18 times this
[ __ ] by me
that was all me
11 times coziel
he was on the wheat too
i only got blocked four times
got stolen from once stole from him
twice
sorry blue you got [ __ ]
look at that [ __ ] eight roads
connected
didn't have to enact my master plan
what a beautiful beautiful flawless
victory by me hans kim of hanskim.com
um but yeah i uh i'm having a good time
um
[Music]
overall i would say that i'm doing good
um
what is your next podcast i like the
last one you did oh thanks man you know
some people say that my
podcasting skills are subpar and that
i'm boring and i don't know how to hold
the conversation but to them i say
um
yeah this is so weird and awkward like
why are you so weird man this is so
stupid
uh that's what i feel like tony and joe
were talking about you on the podcast a
couple days ago yeah i posted it on my
instagram and my twitter and my facebook
i posted it everywhere i'm pretty much a
[ __ ]
these are there are two job openings for
every available workers now is the time
to unionize annoyance labor and
negotiate and unionize
when's your next podcast like the last
one you did oh you mean the sound was
bad the one with the sound you mean with
like four or five people in it the
the children from dallas that came in
with eddie trevino and anne and
shiva that was a good podcast i had a
good
time i trounced these fools i doubled
the amount of points
um but uh
yeah
you gotta win no matter what it takes
victory points or
longest road they're all points man
all points are created equally in the
eyes of god
lord god almighty
he deems us worthy or not
um
hi hans i love you the sound was bad
because i think i was playing the audio
the audio was coming in through the mics
that we all had but i think the audio
was also coming in through the camera so
there was like a slight echo which was
bad
but it's easy to fix i'm going to go to
the creek soon and do other people so
stay tuned for that i just wanted to do
a little podcast
um
i think that
an important thing to do is to um
you know unionize and fight against
capital
with collective bargaining because if we
don't then they're they just become too
powerful we can't just let them win like
you need to compete capitalism is all
about competition and if you don't
compete then you're not going to have a
healthy ecosystem if you just let rich
people dominate then it's going to turn
into a shitty world and i think that
the way that the world is now it's not
bad because we are too
um
like because rich people aren't powerful
enough i think the problems that happen
now are because rich people are too
powerful and we need more power for the
workers
and i think that is uh what we need now
obviously unions aren't perfect there's
a lot of inefficiencies that happen but
i think that letting the rich use the
country and the world as a playground
has some horrific consequences and the
slight technological improvements that
they bless us and gift us with are not
worth the
millions starving and dying
and that we should create a better world
um i think that capitalism won the cold
war
and all the problems that exist now are
because of capitalism not because of
communism communism lost so you really
can't blame them for the state of the
world when they are losers
we are the winners and what did we do
with this winning we did nothing we
created a worse world
i think it's like
they wanted to preserve power amongst
the rich
and communism was a threat to that
they're like we can't have this we need
all the power to stay with the rich and
then they won and they're like oh yeah
keeping power and all the money with the
rich is a good strategy at one let's
keep doing that
and then it had the obvious negative
consequences of poor people dying
and
[Music]
creating a shitty world and a world
where rich people use the planet and the
poor for their own personal gain and
their own luxury
so we need to sort of
course correct and figure our [ __ ] out
and what we need to curtail isn't being
compassionate and nice and being
thinking about the world as a larger
place what we need to curtail is um
selfishness and greed and uh not caring
about the suffering of others
and that is a good thing to to fix
lamell this is so nerdy
starcraft next
um yeah i could play starcraft
uh i haven't played in a while so i'm a
bit rusty
but i can give it a shot
oh yes let's give it a shot
a little starcraft
but uh yeah i mean
what else is going on um you know johnny
depp and amber heard are fighting in the
courts and i think um
it was a shitty relationship and it's
good to know that beautiful people like
that can be in
worse relationships than i'm in
i'm better at being in a relationship
than those two hot [ __ ] maybe it was
really really hot in the beginning and
then it turned sort of shitty
but uh you know
it's like they they haven't got their
[ __ ] figured out i mean i think
relationships are tricky because no
matter how good you are at it it doesn't
matter it can still turn shitty because
you're talking with a person you're in a
relationship with another person
so
they can be
like people are the greatest adversaries
they're the greatest prey you know like
even if you got your [ __ ] figured out
that doesn't mean that uh
you're gonna do great in a relationship
i think that um
what it takes is humility and the
willingness to concede your identity to
be a part of a larger relationship and
if you're doing that with a toxic person
who's not going to appreciate
that then it's a bad relationship
like it takes a degree of vulnerability
to be in a relationship and to give up
your
autonomy to be in a relationship and i
think that
a lot of americans are incapable of
doing that
because we are a culture of selfish
individuals and we value the individual
like i'm gonna be me it's all about me
you can't you know
think about others
and i know that i'm i'm sort of putting
it in harsh terms like you got to give
up your
autonomy but i think it's not such a
bad thing i don't think relationships
where you give up your autonomy is a bad
thing i think it's a beautiful thing to
sacrifice part of yourself to be a part
of something larger and i think it
doesn't make you weaker i think it makes
you stronger i think it makes you
stronger to be
part of a hive mind
and i think that hive minds get a bad
rap
rap rep in america
i mean i'm asian so i love a good hive
mind
but
i just gotta turn down the lighting a
little bit
but uh yeah i mean i think that um
you got to be able to be vulnerable and
be able to let people into your brain
and into your heart into your [ __ ] and
into your vagina
and i think that
if you do that to the wrong person that
they can really [ __ ] [ __ ] up in there
and i think we have like a bunch of
people who are like it's all about me me
me me
oh get out of my way it's my time to
shine i'm the queen i'm the best and i
think a lot of those people are
incapable of being in relationships and
they they're incapable of sacrificing
themselves to be a part of something
larger
and i think that it's looked upon as
weakness to do that in america to be
like oh i'm not gonna
listen i'm just gonna be me
or whatever and i think that's bad i
think that we need to be able to
sacrifice
our individual autonomy for
a larger thing
and it's not
about always
being alone and being your own self and
not thinking about others it's about who
you sacrifice for how you sacrifice
and how you meld with others
that becomes your personality not about
just you being alone all the time and
making every decision yourself like it's
good to have someone that
is the bodyguard and someone else is a
quick
clean person it's good to delineate
because we are
uh
we excel within boundaries it's not just
about just being the best at everything
if you are specialized and you are good
at your role
then you can shine more than if you have
to be good at chopping wood and
blogging and you know instagramming and
uh martial arts and making a taco like
if you could just pick one of those
things and get good at it that's
you being the most to you and instead
we're all doing everything on our own
and we're spreading ourselves thin and
we're not accruing the benefit of doing
something
singular for a long period of time
we're wasting a lot of our energy
doing all this other [ __ ] but there is
something to be said for doing a lot of
other [ __ ] and learning how to learn and
getting good at getting good at things
whatever uh bro what without
individualism there is no innovation but
without collectivism there is no
innovation as well because you won't
want to do a lot of awesome [ __ ] for
other people i don't even care you're a
socialist me me me and relearning to be
my own mommy
i think we need to come together i think
coming together is a lot of benefits and
is really awesome and i think just being
by yourself and stuff is great being
self-reliant is a great thing
um
but i
i think that you need both and i think
right now we're more leaning towards one
direction and than the other and which
direction do you think it is you think
we're too individualistic or too
collective the idea of individualism won
out during the cold war so obviously
we're not individualistic or we're not
collective enough
we're too individualistic and look at
what the world is like we all know it
feels inherently wrong
so if you want to fix [ __ ] you got to do
something different you can't just keep
doing the same thing and expect it to be
different
let me
switch things over for a
bit man it looks
it's all so grainy over there that's the
green screen
um
oh [ __ ] this guy's shooting guns
oh my god
racism in england uh let's watch
something crazy we can react to
how left is the american left and
why didn't socialism catch on here
it's so crazy these like left wing
channels and how many commercials they
have it's like you're supposed to be
left-wing why do you sell yourself out
so much
uh i thought you didn't believe in
capitalism
uh don t that's false china japan are
responsible for
many things throughout history and
individuality isn't part of the culture
bi-directional
been believing less and less in humanity
lately watch live pd that would be great
gold han's reactions
um but yeah i mean um china and japan
are great america's has also had a lot
of innovations through individualism
i think you need both i think asians
need to be more individualistic and i
think americans need to be more
collective i think we need to meet in
the middle
on the video on this video oh i think i
know what's happening
i think the mic is picking [ __ ] up
here let me turn it down
political explainer videos okay don't
actually close your eyes or you'll miss
that gorgeous premium stock footage
and actually don't imagine being a
political youtuber either or you'll fall
into this is this better
you know what just just let me imagine
it for you
dealing is very innovative china is
innovating on stealing
that it's been almost two years since
you made a video about the american
political spectrum it's your second most
pop had so many more let's imagine now
would you remake that video but this
time allowing yourself to take a big
dive into the week's episode we're
looking at the american left in an
international context and answering the
question why did socialism never really
take root here let's talk about the
american left first
radical left the left in this country
they don't give a damn about truth or
justice everything on the left is
collapsing across the board they want to
take
your pickup marxists
wrong every single time this is what
stalin dreamt about but
symbol
and memory
of our national heritage
when we talk about the left in this
country it's important to understand who
that is and for this episode we mean the
elected left so really just the
democratic party there's a whole list of
small parties and groups even with its
own plot of land on the political
spectrum's left wing but since they
occupy next to no major elected
positions and primarily operate through
influence they don't make for a very
robust analysis of american electoral
politics so with all that in mind we're
really just going to focus on the blue
team democrats are the center left party
in the us look that's what it says right
here on wikipedia but what's this when
you plot their voting records and party
discourse on the political compass the
completely neutral absolutely zero bias
omnipotently objective metric of what
politics are you don't get a center-left
party you get a center-right party how
come
the issue here is that left and right
are relative terms there is no
objective left or objective right that
left and right is so weird
um i mean i think the democrats are more
like republicans i don't think
republicans are more like democrats i
think the problems that exist in america
are because republicans
are republicans and democrats act like
republicans not because republicans are
acting like democrats
yeah china had a lot of innovation
um
yeah holds true in every scenario and
can reliably be attached to a certain
set of policies across all of time and
space what is considered radical and
progressive is constantly updated as
political battles evolve and by the same
token what is considered conservative or
reactionary changes when the left
succeeds in making its goals mainstays
or the right reaches further back into
the past for its political program this
basically means that in a country with
only two viable parties you're going to
get one party that calls itself the
right and one that calls itself the left
regardless of where their parties end up
on your political grid they can't both
claim to be on the same side so those
labels end up being about which team you
like better not some marker of absolute
truth so then why does the compass look
like that even if you disagree with its
methodology the reason that the
political compass maps prominent
american politicians so
okay yeah
america america is on the left or
whatever or on the right america is a
slightly right-wing country
i mean not slightly it's pretty much the
biggest right-wing country
in the modern world
and then we shape the rest of the world
to be more right-wing
um but uh yeah i mean i i like second
thought i think like he's good i just
i mean i think like he's
sometimes he doesn't see the whole
picture that well but
you know neither do i
i definitely need to find a better way
of defining the left and right or just
get rid of it all together and maybe
have boards likes to govern themselves
like let town cities govern themselves
what about the mexicans but who is
censoring speech joe and ellen think the
liberal left and move to left
uh left right both benefit by retaining
their power nothing changing with the
appearance of being at odds with the
opposite side
okay left right both benefit by
retaining the power and nothing changing
with the appearance of being at all to
the opposite sides
well i think the right wing is a lot
more
intransigent and unwilling to work with
the other party than the democrats are
uh you know mitch mcconnell during
obama's presidency would not do anything
for obama and
he was just like yeah just
i'm gonna [ __ ] up the country i'm gonna
let the budget or like the let the
funding for the government fall
and everyone's gonna blame obama no
one's gonna blame me because people
aren't paying attention to
politics that
much so i think that
that kind of
thinking was
from the republican side way worse than
the democrats
joe and elon think the liberal left have
moved to left here's my problem with the
democrats is that they don't want to
give up any of their money
they would rather have bathrooms
and you know
like adopt black children
and you know do these little protests
but they don't the one thing that they
don't want is to give up their suburban
homes or to
live in a slightly smaller house
you know live next to more people they
don't want to
live a shittier life and all their
they're logically on board but like
emotionally they'd rather still have
their wealth so all their [ __ ]
um
uh all their policies are based on like
helping like the equality and stuff but
without giving up any of their money
they want to keep their money and that's
the biggest thing about them is they
want to preserve their wealth
so you know they're on board with the
bathrooms and [ __ ] anything that won't
actually make any financial difference
which is the only thing that really
matters
so i think that um
they would rather just be like hey we
support trans and you know we love all
this [ __ ] and let them play sports
but none of this has anything to do with
money and helping people that are
struggling and they don't want to give
up any other money and in that way
they're republicans
um
so
that's the biggest issue is like they
don't want to actually restructure their
society economically and if you don't
do it with money nothing is going to
change money is the only thing that
matters and that is the only thing that
they don't want to change
i think the left has been like oh let's
just get more into transgender it's like
overcorrecting from the gay [ __ ] they're
like oh gay marriage is obviously
correct and they [ __ ] it up on that
one so let's just over
do it with the trans support
and let's not give the black people or
mexicans any money
and without giving people money like
nothing's going to change but who is
censoring speech
i think that both sides are censoring
speech i mean i think
like republicans ban books they're like
oh this is a book about gay people you
shouldn't have this or like evolution
like who is censoring that
i think republicans do it in a way where
it's more accepted because it's been
censored that way for such a long time
that we just think it's normal and then
democrats are like oh no this tweet is
hurting my feelings or whatever
but um
i mean
do you think that uh
i i think that uh
the censorship of speech happens because
some of these ideas are so obviously
wrong and like
republicans are so obviously incorrect
that it's easy to be like we we don't
want to listen to this [ __ ] anymore what
the [ __ ] are you doing like you're we're
still arguing about whether gay people
are people or not or if black people
deserve to live in uh
a normal home and [ __ ] like
this isn't a debate like you're just
doing this for
um selfish reasons and it's not arguing
in good faith
um
but yeah i mean
it's
it's easy to um you know be defending
free speech when
you are not dying or starving and you
the world looks pretty much the way that
you want it to look